[Music]
hi and welcome back to schism psychology
today I'm going to show you ideally two
games and tell you about how preparing
before the game accurately helped me
have an easier game it sounds very
logical but some people just don't
really like preparing or don't really
know how to do it accurately so the
things that you could know before the
game you kind of end up spending so much
time and energy and trying to hopefully
find it in the game and also the fact
that just being able to detect your
opponent's weaknesses especially in
openings it gives you the chance to try
and exploit them more rather than just
going to the game and playing plain
chess
so let's dive in so this is a game that
I had to it good night mama dada she had
more rating back then pretty sure she is
more rating now but in this specific
game I was better prepared and yeah this
was in World Junior Chess Championship
2015 2015 was one of the one of my big
ears I played so many tournaments I was
playing tournaments pretty much every
month and yeah alright so uh I do
remember that before the game I knew
that she was a big neither player and if
I remember correctly she had another
game in the same tournaments earlier
round that she played night off so the
big idea that neither F is that black
wants to simply play e5
kick your knight away and then try to
simply develop with Bishop e6 push every
seven maybe 97 maybe nice c6
and their White has a lot of different
variations on how to put a proceed white
could try to try for a long cast though
like with Bishop e3 Queen d2 f3 or
something like Bishop g5 which is one of
the big lines or White's could simply
try to do short caster like Bishop comes
to e 2 this should be 2 and then you
just simply do short Castle so there are
a lot of different ideas and so usually
players stick to one or two of them and
switch between them but I thought I had
a little bit of wider range of what to
play against neither that's I like
necessarily wouldn't have played it on a
like if I was just playing it's right
now is in a friendly game I probably
wouldn't play Bishop c4 but in this game
and I did and it was kind of also one of
those moves that it is very interesting
it's very classic it's not too many
crazy ideas recently I've seen a lot of
different players and try to go for some
stuff like maybe rooks g1g for h3g for
yeah so I decided to go for Bishop c4
mainly because she did have a game
earlier in the same tournaments
different rounds and her opponents also
play Bishop c4 and so it was easier for
me to prepare against it so if you're
pulling a tournament and you happen to
see that your opponent's play the game
in the same line that you might want to
play it is a good idea to consider it
more seriously especially because
usually when players win the game they
don't really go and check their games as
deeply as they would when they lose the
game so it is a good idea to even if
your opponent won that game for you to
go and play it against them if you're
prepared so
um Essex is the the good move to play
because if something like a five here if
black were to play e5 the problem is
that wherever you put the knight this d5
square is already super weak and you
already are dominating it you could
probably just simply go night after you
could try for something like 92 and then
you might want to do something like this
you have different ideas and there is no
there is it takes I mean it should be to
your preference but the idea is that the
d5 square is super weak and you're just
gonna jump in it so II six is the move
that's been played for decades maybe
more and after a six the idea is that
life simply wants to try and play b5 and
maybe push for B for especially because
this Knight is protecting this bond so
black is trying to go after white spawns
so this move Bishop e3 is one of those
good moves that's slightly prophylactic
and it's simply if if I were to play
something else
after b5 I kind of was going to play
Bishop e3 anyways so it makes more sense
to play Bishop b3 now and it's not as
pro it's not provoking b5 anymore so she
did play b5 first I mean it was the main
line at the time and also b5 still
follows the same ideas maybe before
maybe Queen b6 because black needs to
create some space in the Queen sides
because if black were to simply just
play Bishop e7 and shorts cast off White
has way too much space this Bishop here
is really nice putting more pressure on
e6 pawn on f7
so here after b5
I played Bishop g5 the idea is kind of
simple if if black were to play before
after I move this night my e4 pawn is no
longer under attack because of that this
knight is pinned also be shovin g5 is a
very nice square to be because next move
you could try to do something like Queen
f3 and put more pressure here also I
prepared this before the game after
Bishop e7 Queen f3 so now you see the
Queen f3 is not only attacking the
knight it's also has some ideas on this
roof because it's currently defenseless
so if it were white to move again
probably something like e 5 was at least
worst worth considering if not winning
so after Queen of set f3
what do you think black should do
ninety-seven
okay so you just want to ignore it and
you want to develop I think the problem
is if you were to play something like 97
I would get this knight c6 ideas even if
II five doesn't work which I mean
technically okay II five you could try
to take and if I take the rook you could
take this night so it there could be
some compensation so yeah I think I
would be more comfortable playing
something like where instead of 97
what's right to move it's white to move
instead of Knight to d7 you want Bishop
is yeah I think Bishop e7 is a pretty
logical move and Bishop e7 should be
played either now or slightly later
because this Bishop doesn't really have
a future in this diagonal and to simply
think about it this Bishop does belong
to b7 so you might as well do it now to
avoid any kind of tactics at E 5 s so
she decided to play Queen b6 claim u6 is
also a good move I'm also pretty sure it
was reparation and the thing is with
Queen b6 now e5 is kind of sketchy
because you could simply just take like
if I play e5 you could just take if I
take a 8 now you're sucking my knight
and you might have some ideas with
castile Bishop d7 trying to trap my
Queen over here so that's something that
I thought
wasn't really worth playing a five after
queen v6 I wanted to play simple chess
so I looked at long castle and now I do
want to play e5 because if if I've you
take I still can take on a H but when
you take on d4 I could play Knight e 2
and my pieces are more ready to march on
your king
so after 97 that I do get kind of dials
down a little because if e5 there's
always this Bishop e7 2 and now I have
to decide where to put my queen and when
I move the Queen somewhere then this e 5
pawn is hanging and just Knight takes e5
and black just picks up my pawn so here
take a little bit of time and tink after
97 as white how do you want to move
forward keep in mind that with black
there are few moves such as Bishop e7
and shorts Castle like these two moves
are but most likely blacks next to move
regardless of what you do so think about
how do you want to march on the King
side
yeah
suggestion from chat 23 I like that idea
but what are your next few moves so you
want your queen on g3 what else another
way to think about it
Queen g3 is indeed a good move even if
not right now but the Queen the Queen's
job on f3 is done because the Queen on
f3 can't really do anything else even
though it's kind of like attacking the
knight maybe keeping an eye on the rook
maybe after this pitch after pitch this
Bishop e7 it's the bishop who is kind of
annoying the Queen so it's the time it's
time to think about another square for
the Queen so I do like the idea queen g3
maybe not immediately but or even
immediately but my question is more like
where else do you want your other pieces
to be
we should take six weeks context night
takes and my skin can't castle
taking on e6 immediately is not if it's
good idea to think about because it kind
of helps you remember that this e six is
weak but right now I don't believe it
works because least of all could simply
take I think could simply take back and
this nicely five kind of attacks your
night with the bishop night
I'm just kind of shooting moves here but
I I'm not as comfortable playing
something like this I just my pieces are
not that's ready also maybe even not
taking immediately maybe something about
95 should first should be okay - yeah
and now where do you want to place your
queen if you play like winners tree now
I can take and now I can't think about
king f7 take what you want to take like
f7
yeah that's like that's the point it is
a little too soon to take on e6 but it
is it is a good idea to keep it in mind
because it will come up later again and
it's not about not letting black
Castille because okay for example if you
didn't have this e4 pawn like if this
pawn was out of the boards then yeah you
kind of wanted to open up the file on
the King so you might consider
sacrificing more seriously like playing
with rook e1 stuff like that but this
pawn is kind of not allowing your pieces
to attack the King directly even if in
the king is in the center
so you want to just bring your Bishop
back I don't think it's a bad idea but I
think between Bishop III and the idea
with Quincy 3:23 is better because you
simply play Quincy tree and you have
more ideas how to attack the king after
the King plays short castle you could
think about something like Bishop h6 so
in the game I went with rook e1 again
still home prep but I knew it wasn't
just that I remembered the moves I knew
the ideas behind them and that's
something that we usually make mistakes
like when we are trying to memorize
something we kind of just go by our
memory instead of trying to understand
it and something that really helps me
understand why like how to remember the
move is to question myself so where does
this piece belong what I'm trying to do
with this piece ideally where could I
try ideally and realistically how can I
maneuver this piece so these are some of
those stuff that I try to ask myself
even if I'm learning a new opening even
if I'm preparing some line against some
opponents it's not just about the moves
like I'll move 11 I'm gonna play rook e1
it's not like that it's you kind of have
to understand why you're doing it
so rook e1 is a good move because you're
developing the rook there are other
ideas that you could start to push over
here maybe h4 h5 and after short Castle
you would like have a pawn over here
that wasn't really what I was going for
this bringing the rook at is a better
idea castle now Queen g3 I do want to
play Queen is sick
Bishop h6 and go for the g7 mates but
black simply played 95
so now it's white to move again could
you tink and let me know what dudes how
do you think white should proceed so
what are some of the ideas for white
it's white to move black dress played 9
c5
I like the idea the this over six
doesn't work yeah and also I think mmm
not even is five something's more simple
than that just 98 to keep control so now
that you see Bishop f6 doesn't work even
though you did Queen g3 do you think
Queen on g3 is happy or could it be in a
better place because the idea with
Bishop h6 Queen takes g7 isn't the only
mate that you can think of
there is another maneuver that you could
go for yeah what is your idea
yeah usually rooks do like third ranks
it not necessarily third ranks but just
being a little above the pond the pawn
structure so if I have all of my pawns
on the second rank Myrick does like to
be on third rank this is pretty cool
because now you want to do stuff like
Queen h4 rook each tree and go for this
guy so the way that so the thing is even
though this looks pretty cool and white
is doing everything logical and just
developing and making simple moves and
white development looks better and
everything this is still a pretty equal
position and I knew that before the game
so this should be seven Queen h4 now
black needs to open up some room to
breathe so rook c8 now rook g3 I simply
want to take notes so how do you think
black can save the night
that's one way the problem is as soon as
you move this night the e6 square a day
six pawn gets kind of weird so you could
now start thinking about sacrifices here
and after you move the King and the
night is still pinned so what other
options
it's blackton quindi 8 yeah I think we
do it is one of the ideas but I don't
think it works right now because even if
Queen d8 this if I Vox very tempting and
now this night could jump around
probably take an e6 is the way to go or
even 95 [ __ ] I mean both of them look
good and good so so what is the problem
with this night the fact that this g7
pawn is pinned right so how can you
unpin it yeah so King King f8 is
actually the the best move
and so after King f8 I can't really take
on f6 anymore theoretically I could but
it's not really good because I could try
to go for this pawn but also there is
this little tactic here and now my rook
was already so far so good
cool so after King f8 I do remember
that's when I was looking at this back
in the hotel before the game I was like
well King f8 the best Pope that computer
was suggesting again at the time was
rook f3 and I did prepare a chemistry
and to my understanding I just wanted to
sacrifice over here and so I don't want
to give up the move what do you think
it's the best move for black
think about what were the problems last
move and Eric was on g3 and think if
they still apply is expand if you play
Knight g8 f7 pawn is pinned so I can
just do Knight ecigs check
yeah actually
kingi it is the best move you just go
back because the idea is that now again
whites best move is to play with g3 and
repeat and it is kind of funny so when I
was looking at it before the game I
didn't I wasn't really looking to make a
draw but the way I talked myself into
playing this line I was like if she can
come up to the board and just find all
of these moves and be mentally okay with
just prepare like perpetual well that is
the line and that is what the position
is going for so I was like talking
myself into it and so she didn't play
King g8 I didn't get a chance to ask her
after the game I thought that might be
mean so she played before but I think
another one of the moves that could have
been better is like Queen c7 or maybe
rook c7 so the idea simply after like if
I do some takes over here like black is
trying and why cos is still slightly
better but it's nothing like what
happened in the game and so look let's
look at Queen c7 - if Queen c7 do you
think the sacrifices still works
taking on f6
okay so you
and that is in a way
so you can't just take with the pickup
and then do this this version of
sacrifice but it is kind of again draw
yeah I didn't believe if she could find
it she deserves half a point
so now it's I'm still having some ideas
on e6 square I might want to try and
push for a five I want I might want to
simply just do check check check it
depends on the blacks next move but this
is equal position and most likely would
have ended in a draw but after before I
was this is I was out of preparation
already move 17 haha and I was so thick
the moves that I was thinking about was
alright so I gotta move this night what
should I do with this or do I have to
move the night and I just take on f6 so
take a little bit of time and think
about this because it's pretty nice and
there are a lot of takes and threads in
the position so
so what are the moves you're thinking it
with what are your candidate news
Wow mechanicals
I was out of prevention good good
well
first
see some 95 that's actually pretty cool
but I don't think it works it doesn't
necessarily have to be a crazy move it
could just be about which piece of your
opponent is kind of annoying you and try
to exchange it off so okay let me let me
rephrase the question which piece of
black do you think is the strongest like
holding gets all together not well not
all but defending a lot of things you
want to attack
ix and c5 or f6 you get to pick only one
ah thank you
yeah nice a four is actually the move I
went for when I played night a four
I thought that she would play night
b-tree and that my my thought process
was that all right
least of all this night can hang here
and there is no more attack and now I
can focus on creating something over
here and probably something like Queen
a5 I would have taken and some crazy
ideas or if like whoops if Queen c7 I
could just try to go for this check
check again if King g8 Perpetual if rook
e8 rook e1 with bringing the other row
came and if King e8 just defending the
c2 pawn
do you think my d4 Knight and so these
are the moves that I was looking at I
went over Queen eight five too fast
let's look at it one more time if Queen
a5 take if take with pond just take on
it seven and this should be good enough
if Bishop takes f6 you can give this
check if F takes G 6 there is rook and
this list of all there is a there's a
perpetual and if not there should be
rook t3 burning in the other broken if
now King goes away be cautious because
your queen is under attack so you kind
of have to take it and you just save the
nice so it's like two nights yeah it is
two nights and one rook against you not
to rooks and one Bishop so it's an
exchange down but it is a good strategic
idea because you can do this check d6 is
following f6 is weak
so this is something that would be a
good idea to look at and the way to
understand how is after sink night comes
to a four you're simply creating a
distraction for this night and night a
four is kind of losing on spot but night
Petrie would have had a better fight
because even though white has a better
attack white has to be very precise
there is after night a four it's not
that hard to come up with the winning
plans we've been looking at it for the
past few minutes so what do you think is
the winning plan
why did we want the night from c5 to be
distracted away
so you can be six yeah
so do you think it's the time to take on
e6 or do you prefer to just take on 84
taking on a four I think it's a mmm it
is a good idea and strategically kind of
makes sense but your Bishop on a four is
not doing anything so to me it didn't
make much sense to take on a four so
yeah the idea was that you see the way
to start thinking about how to make
these kind of decisions to sacrifice is
usually it works if you don't like take
back immediately so here if after a
night a four take you take back it
whoops if you take on a four immediately
you don't even get the chance to see
other moves so the way to try and teach
yourself not to immediately take back
and to see these kind of intermediate
moves such as Knight takes c6 it's that
it is a very nice an efficient idea to
try to teach yourself to organize your
candidate moves by first checks then
takes and then use the treads or like
takes bags and stuff like that and so
you only have one check in this position
and that's 96 so you do have a bunch of
other takes on up sticks that I do think
are also efficient but it doesn't
necessarily work right now so it is a
better idea to take on e6 first open up
the King and then go for the this attack
so I've already told you that this is
winning but try to find the winning line
it is black to move so think about what
if does it actually matter if black
would take with bishop or pawn and what
would your move be after both of those
moves
okay
if king GH
nanus mate yeah so King has to go to e8
so it regardless of taking it upon or
the bishop whoops well actually taking
the pawn queen takes h7 should be more
clear win but in this position what if
King g8
yeah
and how do you finish it off
I wanna say you have made into
yeah Bishop f5 is a good idea I was also
looking at wreckage 6 because if take we
have six mates if not wreckage 7 is
coming mate
probably other there are other moves
that went to which other five should
also be winning enough but yeah so King
can't run away so has to take back now
what do we do
I agree King g8 we shall tasty sings
mates right so the King has to go the
other way now how do you win this
it looks wedding but you still need to
find it
remember keep thinking about checks and
takes
that is one check
it's another check what about your
Bishop what is your bishop doing there
so that's another check so yeah these
are the moves that it's a good idea to
calculate so take a little bit of time
calculate these
okay
either
yeah mmm yes but no yeah because if
Queenie six king the age group takes d6
it is good and realistically should be
winning but it's you're giving your
opponent some chance to try and come up
with stuff because whoops
realistically this is this is still
should be winning but it is to drugs
versus the Queen and will bunch of pawns
and it's simply not the cleanest win it
is it is good but so what if Bishop c6
oops
what if Bishop so what now
in this specifics I mean I think rook t6
is winning enough if Bishop takes a
forward rook takes b6 or queen takes e6
check first and then take the queen and
then it would be a rook and Bishop
versus the Queen and bunch of pawns and
also a lot of checks are happening so I
do think that rook takes T six is
winning enough but maybe Queenie six is
also good now maybe you could try it
with T three you want to try and
checkmate over here one thing that
worries me is what if you just black
tries to bring in rings reinforcements
again it shouldn't really work but I
kind of if it was in the real game I
probably would have just went to route
t6 because if now take simply take check
or take this now you have you want to
play Rocky six you might want to even
give check here play rook p7 so
that's what I was thinking about and
what if rook c6
Texas's
ideally I like my queen on f6 because
it's kind of like keeping the king weary
in the center cause if Queen e6 the king
could try to go to f8 it again it should
still be winning so yeah I think that's
the more of the more efficient way
but again either of them should be
winning enough so find the win it's
so you want to play Bishop c6
oops
hold on you want to take this with the
rook candy seven
King c8
the black king feels like it's kind of
slipping away and I don't like it I like
here you have a much more clear win it
doesn't have to be mates you can just
try to eat so many pieces that black
castor design Queen D 8 then Queen just
comes to e7 but you're just a bunch of
pawns we want pieces real pieces and
then Bishop takes back again that's also
winning but we're looking for clear win
no chance for your opponent to try and
come back
no I want the most clear winning the
clearest no from right now
kingi seven
remember you are one food rock down well
not fool because they're a bunch of
pawns but you are a rope down
why hasn't any what it suggests that
Queen takes ecigs
no not in this position you said it to
move before yeah well do you see okay
you did say it here and then I said well
the King might go to f8 and like Queen
e6 here is such a clear win King f8 you
just give a check again if King goes to
g8 Bishop b3 win if King goes back
whoops well she resigned but if King
goes back to e8 so what's the difference
between this pawn being here or not what
yeah and now you have one more piece
that's going after the rook you can just
simply take you can just do rook c6
Bishop c6 Bishop c6 check even if rook
d7 you take it Twin Falls yeah rook
takes is a slightly more tricky because
you're attacking the Queen there's no
way that the Queen can run off to that
you won't hunt it down and take it
because the next movies would check and
also if take you just take the King
can't go anywhere it's a root T 7 and
just take yeah so it was a clear the
most clear win and a lot of other things
are still better and winning but yeah
this was also kind of the most painful
one and yeah I did have another game
prepared that we didn't really get into
because this game got a lot tactic here
that intended so we will go over at the
other game next time and I hope you
liked it it was pretty cool
and
yeah I do think that the last chance my
opponent had was earlier when she took
here Knight takes a four I think after
this the game was pretty one-sided I was
just chasing and I was just taking and
sacrificing and I'm not complaining but
Knight III would have been kind of
harder on me
so maybe in your game if you end up
being in the black side just try to find
the moves that are most annoying to your
opponent because Knight xb3
at least of all it reduces the threat on
e6 pawn because the bishop isn't here
anymore
and also the knight on a 4 is sort of
misplaced even though you won't have as
any kind of attack with black after a
takes b3 but the knight is misplaced so
yeah try to think try to put yourself in
your opponent's shoes and think what
would be the most annoying to me and try
to do that as opponent yeah that's kind
of all we have time for today hope you
enjoyed it
[Music]
you